mais pour lui les soul est racontée dans
tera ce que tu fais là
c'est une blague l'agent rock ou pas
rock été magnifique c'est la dernière de
dvmp ce soir attention spéciale
attention c'est show est mon chéri je
pense à jean roch
parce que mine de rien mongeau rock tu
nous a fait rêver pendant des années on
a pêché grâce à toi en boîte de nuit
on a on a kiffé on a sauvé voilà les
piscines à danser comme des fous et là
alors c'est vrai que les restaurateurs
ont ouvert j'oserais dire merci aux jean
baptiste de nous accueillir
c'est d abord merci à vous tous merci
beaucoup et on espère qu'ils allaient
bosser comme des fous aller les voir
c'est les mecs j'ai causé des amours et
franchement il faut leur faire
travailler les restaurateurs les gens
qui travaillent les barmans tout ça ils
ont besoin de nous tous les
restaurateurs et bravo merci nous avait
bien merci vous aider à bon escient et
on va tout faire pour que ça bosse ce
que vous en avez besoin
et c'est des mecs jean baptiste à
boulogne merci à vous encore une fois
nous à des amours voilées franchement où
on les fait chier à chaque fois et tous
et des amours de m merci beaucoup et son
rock et je crois qu'on a besoin aussi
des discothèques mon chéri là parce que
on est dans une salle parce que notre
président puis la parole en disant que
tout allait ouvrir tout allait
redémarrer le péril économie et son
ministre la santé hier monsieur vers ans
a tenu un discours l'assemblée kéké un
incompréhensible
il faut absolument que les clubs réouvre
cet été partout et pas qu'à paris dans
la france entière sur la cote
il faut absolument
ah merde catastrophe
il faut absolument que le clubbing
revois je suis discothèque
vous devez soutenir les discothèques je
vous demande soutenir tous les
discothèques
il faut que nous rouvrirons merci mon
jeu rock d'être un thème fort et jean
roch et c'est vrai parce qu'on pense à
tous les restaurateurs qui ont ouvert il
faut faire travailler la france est
était un mine de rien faut faire
travailler nos amis voilà et nos amis
des restaurateurs dans toute la france
les bars les restaurants voilà tout ça
parce que franchement on a besoin d'eux
et les mecs y à quoi et à qui à quoi
comme plus grand kiff que d'aller boire
un verre en terrasse comme ici avec des
potes croissant c'est ce qui nous a le
plus manqué pendant le confinement
vraiment voilà on les soutient à fond et
merci au journaliste merci le genre
vraiment vous êtes des amours merci les
chiffres immersion ouf